we caught up with demographics
researcher halleloo tkachev ski in
brussels he's been investigating the
differences between the concerns younger
and older voters have and what impact
that has on election outcomes including
the brexit vote so why do young and old
people vote differently either is a
novella ki Colback article page is a
broad category that tends to concealer
the factors the u.s. election and the
brexit vote have given us some very
interesting insights in fact one bactrim
trump supporters for example tend to be
more concerned about immigration and
cultural identity and seem to be
concerned that the former white majority
will fall behind EMI Spicer Mia hides
him it was a sh dair considered heaven
so it wasn't economic questions Percy we
heard a lot about the idea that Trump
supporters tended to have economic
concerns that was a factor but more
importantly it was about a question of
culture farha visa deserve a swash
gentleman cultural identity was an issue
when it came to brexit too there was a
sharp divide between how young and old
voted only a quarter of young people
voted in favor of Britain leaving the EU
the older the voter the more likely they
were to want out so older voters made a
decision that shaped the younger
generations future that anger brought
many young people out onto the streets
so will we see this generational divide
in other countries how much sway do
older voters hold no it's an inverted a
step to see brexit that we were
interested in how a brexit style
referendum might have played out in
other countries what would the
demographic impact have been in Germany
the US or Australia we created an index
and looked at 19 different countries and
found that in each one of them the
younger generation would have been on
the losing side so in industrialized
countries populations are aging to such
an extent that whenever there's a strong
difference of opinion between young and
old
older voters will tip the scale so young
and old people certainly hold very
different views the generations seem to
be drifting apart but can that trend to
be reversed how can we bring young and
old together club is that in mind that
one young and old will always differ in
certain ways over the course of our
lives we tend to undergo some changes in
our attitudes and lifestyles that's
something our political leaders should
pay attention to but it's also important
for young people to become more active
politically we know the turnout is
significantly lower among younger voters
and we could also do more to make older
people aware of issues political and
civic education isn't just for young
people as you lift